[Música]
y hablamos de freddie mercury uno de los
artistas más importantes de la historia
de la música a nivel mundial han pasado
30 años desde su muerte pero su legado
permanece vivo mercury murió el 24 de
noviembre de
1991 en cannes y son londres luego de
una exitosa carrera con la agrupación
queen con la que en menos de una década
alcanzó el estatus de leyenda del rock
cantante compositor pianista guitarrista
y señor gráfico y músico como intérprete
ha sido reconocido por su poderosa voz y
también extravagantes puestas en escena
como olvidar para ello quiere saludar
entonces alfredo lewin cofundador
derrocase y puntocom efe gracias a
alfredo por estar con nosotros en
directo américa y hablar del gran
freddie mercury el legado más importante
de mercury para usted cuál es en la
música en la cultura de más
muchas gracias a ustedes por tenerme acá
de invitados desde santiago chile
recordando estos 30 años no es menor
desde 1991 de la muerte de freddie
mercury un único e irrepetible que está
en la liga de elvis presley de aretha
franklin o los que el llamar a sus
grandes influencias incluyendo a montar
acaba ley a luciano pavarotti
porque fue tan exitoso que lo hacía tan
especial y tan querido en la gente
y carismas probablemente el momento
adecuado en el rock glam con intenciones
de proteger y progresivas que marcaron
la inglaterra de finales de los 60 y
principios de los 70 no se había visto
porque si estaba robert plan de led
zeppelin o estaba la gente de yeso genes
y todos estos experimentos como muy
artísticos en el rock pero no había un
tipo que tuviera el carisma y esa esa
sensibilidad no sólo lírica sino que se
despliegue escénico que al corto plazo
de la carrera de queens
carlo profundo también en eeuu a
mediados de los 70 y era una apuesta
bien jugada que podría compararse con la
progresión artística que tuvo otro héroe
que también no está el día de hoy con
nosotros y gran influencia de freddie
mercury que es david bowie en tanto a la
progresión artística setentera y también
pondría a john lennon es en la liga en
la que se mueve freddie mercury en su
desarrollo como personalidad pero
también como líder y principal
compositor
su banda cuenta así es hablemos entonces
de queens y su música alfredo porque que
hace que sus canciones sus melodías
perduren en el tiempo y todavía uno la
ceja la siga cantando como si ese éxito
hubiera salido hoy por ejemplo
bueno hay canciones que son inmortales y
probablemente las que adornan el 1975 en
nairobi ópera y bohemian rhapsody
principalmente que se vio reactualizada
para las nuevas generaciones por la
película de hace un par de años son la
razón por la cual nos damos cuenta que
el rock ha envejecido muy bien el rock
de hace 55 años a partir de el impacto
de the beatles en adelante que es una
influencia para queens así como lo es
también
jimi hendrix y las cosas que se hicieron
en ese gran bretaña muy creativo
psicodélico de finales de los 60 más
allá de todos los efectos y la
ingeniería de sonido son las canciones
las que logran hacerse un paso en el
tiempo y hoy día afortunadamente la
última parte de la carrera de the queen
de principios de los 90 nos muestra un
sonido que perfectamente se puede
escuchar y se puede consumir el día de
hoy y el formato de grandes éxitos de
queens no solamente por el lanzamiento
de discos que se llaman así
probablemente son los discos más
exitosos en la industria discográfica de
todos los tiempos me refiero al queens 1
gates especialmente ahora también
alfredo una de las actuaciones más
notables sin duda de queens fue en 1985
en el concierto live aid en contra
contra el sida precisamente que murió
freddie mercury tras complicaciones por
tener vih que rescata de esta
presentación de
1995 1985 perdón
bueno la de 1985 en en rigor ese no es
por el tema del sida lamentablemente el
tema del sida se escondía en ese tiempo
es el tema de la hambruna en áfrica es
lo que genera la invitación de bob
geldof para que quinn también formará
parte de esa de esa transmitido
transmisión satelital que unió el
estadio de wembley en inglaterra con el
estadio de john fitzgerald kennedy en
filadelfia y esa fecha considerada hasta
el día de hoy como el día del rock y la
performance de queens que duró
veintitantos minutos que era el límite
de cualquier banda para tocar en esa
instancia es considerada la mejor
performance de una banda de rock en
todos los tiempos luego nos confundimos
porque en 1992 hay otra en un wembley
que invitaron a muchísimos artistas y
concitó el interés ya masivo con la
tecnología mejorada de las transmisiones
vía satélite en el mismo wembley en
donde ya se instaló la idea de una
fundación de beneficencia y caridad y
que sobre todo
apuntará a conseguir fondos para
investigar más en profundidad el tema
del virus del sida y ahí efectivamente
eso se hizo meses después de la muerte
de freddie mercury y ahí es donde se
instala la figura de elton jhon por
ejemplo que se hace cargo también de
esta misión que es conseguir fondos para
luego en el tiempo de años de la muerte
de freddie mercury ya se había
conseguido avanzar en el tema de un
retrovirus que aunque no soluciona el
tema del virus del sida si lo aplaca al
punto que hoy día un montón de gente
infectada millones pueden vivir con
normalidad
lamentablemente no hubo dinero ni
investigación en el tiempo de vida de
los últimos años de freddie mercury me
refiero a
1990-91 y freddy lo tenía completamente
asumido estaba resignado a que la cura o
el paliativo para su enfermedad no iba a
llegar
alfredo gracias por esa aclaración
tienes toda la razón y yo me confundí en
estos dos conciertos pero también
hablemos de freddie mercury como solista
incluido el álbum mi ser bad guy de
en colaboró con montserrat caballé en
barcelona en
1988 porque no tuvo mercury tanto éxito
como solista y si lo tuvo con queens
yo creo que mercury no tuvo tanto éxito
como solista porque la magia funcionaba
cuando la suma de las partes y hay algo
más es queen y son los cuatro son john
deacon brian may y roger taylor y estaba
mal asesorado mal producido musicalmente
tenía una idea más o menos clara en
donde quería juntar el mundo de la fit
xeral y cantar como una jazz era de los
40 y al mismo tiempo meter a montserrat
caballé y todo con un ritmo muy dance
con música es más bien electrónica con
vocación de pista de baile que era algo
que probablemente había investigado en
el álbum de 1981 the queen del hot space
pero fue el disco menos exitoso de
queens entonces lo que hizo él fue
continuar una racha poco exitosa
independiente de que hayan un par de
temas rescatables de su disco de solista
él mismo se dio cuenta con el chocó de
frente frente a la evidencia de que 5
simplemente no remontaba y eso también
le pasó a sus compañeros especialmente a
roger taylor el baterista que también
trató de hacer una carrera de fuera de
queen brian may
también está todo y la verdad es que la
hace magia estaba en queens pero yo
diría que también hay una mezcla de mal
manejo
del management que queda más o menos
claro en la película las razones de
aquello y por qué bueno porque él sentía
que podía hacer a una música y decir
algunas cosas que no podía hacer con sus
compañeros de the queen porque ahí había
una lucha de poderes con respecto a la
composición y a la producción y al
arreglo de los temas